and minimalists hello simpletons you may
notice something different right now by
the way I'm Joshua fields Milburn and
then I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less if you're watching this on video
you'll notice that I am in my kitchen
right now and Ryan isn't in the studio
with podcast Sean and was we wanted to
take social distance distancing to the
max this is like heaven for me finally
Ryan I'm able to live out my dreams I
ordered a bunch of mayonnaise jars from
Amazon oh my good I'm gonna be peeing in
them for weeks oh no actually I'm home
because I have some cold symptoms I
don't have any reason to believe that I
have come into contact with Tsarskoe v2
which is the actual name of the novel
coronavirus people often confuse the
corona virus with kovat 19 which is the
resulting disease from SARS Co v2 and so
just to be safe I'm pretty sure I just
have a cold I don't have any of the
major symptoms of of kovat 19 I don't
have a fever I don't have a coffee I've
some symptoms I am NOT a symptomatic and
so I'm recording this from home and this
is a nice little experiment I think for
us Ryan I think you would agree that
right now I mean you know a lot of
podcasters to do things remotely and it
comes out great and yeah I mean it is a
good test I think it's always better for
us to be in the studio together but this
is this is a great plan B if you like
yeah and these are some extenuating
circumstances and so today I wanted to
talk about how to live through this and
that's a bit of a double entendre like
obviously we want to live right like we
want to survive this even if we do get
the resulting disease Co vid 19 even if
I do have that right now which I again I
don't suspect I do but even I do we want
to live through that but also we want to
live through this I truly live
to the best of our abilities considering
in the circumstances so I was hoping
Ryan you and I could record a somewhat
of a quickie episode over the next 20 30
minutes and and talk about some things
that we can really make the best of an
unfortunate situation because I do think
after a lot of reading a lot of
contemplation a lot of self quarantine I
I do believe that we are going to see
some some pretty trying times ahead of
us
and I don't I don't mean to sound
alarmist and and in fact I want to be
the opposite of alarmist I'm very
optimistic about the future and I think
a lot of these changes are gonna get us
outside of our comfort zone and that's a
really good thing you know you go back
and read the Stoics and they'll they're
gonna tell you that if you just stay
within your comfort zone you're going to
atrophy and so this will be a time of
growth for us but not in the way that we
think about growth right it's not GDP
growth in fact Ryan I was just walking
down Melrose Avenue today I was taking
the advice of my doctor one of my
doctors and getting some Sun and it was
a ghost town I mean it was I there were
blocks I walked several blocks on
Melrose Avenue which is like a hopping
mecca right and many blocks
not a single person walked by me you
know what's interesting I went to
Griffith Park earlier today to hike
where the old abandoned Zoo is and it
was like a Saturday there were so many
people and animals oh yeah so I think
getting out in nature is one thing that
we can we can do right now and to use
this time wisely in fact when we're
social distancing that it doesn't mean
that we have to not go out doesn't mean
we have to stay in our homes perpetually
in fact that can be unhealthy because it
can be mentally unhealthy it can be
depressing it can be upsetting for a lot
of people and so we can still practice
social distancing in nature and getting
Sun getting out and in the natural
environment and I find that if we use
this time for that we're gonna be
slowing down all of us are slowing down
and a lot of us are affected our careers
are affected I know Ryan you and I we've
had quite a few you know financial
setbacks because of this but those are
inconveniences and it's unfortunate
thankfully we have an emergency fund and
and we may have to tap into that but uh
we had to cancel an entire tour or at
least postpone it for now and we don't
know how long it's going to be until we
can reschedule that so right now it's
effectively canceled and we had to stop
production on our next Netflix film
lessons now and we had to reschedule all
of that and we're in the mix of
rescheduling it but it's going to take a
lot to reschedule it and also things are
up in the air with the podcast obviously
we're gonna keep doing podcast we might
try to have to try some remote things
like this I know it's not the most ideal
situation but we want to make the best
of these circumstances and so Ryan I put
I put together a few things I pulled
together a few things for this because
we did the pandemic preparation episode
with TK Coleman and the subsequent
maximal episode called coronavirus which
just came out and and and there I think
we covered 95 or some of the things I
wanted to cover but the things that we
didn't cover is I wanted to give some
people some additional perspective and
maybe some reasons to be hopeful in
these times of uncertainty of worry of
anxiety of despair and the first thing
that I thought of here was our friend
Paul Saladino dr. Paul Saladino he's a
medical doctor he had a scientific look
at the corona virus on his podcast
recently and he shared this quote we
pulled up it's on my my Twitter account
you can follow me over there it's just
@j FM if you'd like but he had this
quote from tick not Han who is the
Buddhist monk you all are probably
familiar with him but this this quote
really stood out to me and it
and because a lot of us are panicking
right now or semi panicking Ryan I I
think I shared with you a photo if not
I'll send it to you but a photo of I
went to Target this morning before they
opened and there was a line down the
block to get in to Target and yeah yeah
7:30 a.m. or whatever it was and I just
needed to buy regular supplies I want to
buy a bottle of Lysol and a and so I
showed up with a mask on because I have
a cold and I don't want to get anyone
else sick I also had gloves on and there
was a line and there are a lot of people
panicking as soon as they opened the
doors people were running for paper
towels and then running for all of these
things and really that's not that's not
behaving like a member of of a community
in fact it's it's the opposite people
are panicking we need some people to
display calmness right now and so this
quote from tick not Han was this when
the crowded refugee boats met with
storms or pirates if everyone panicked
all would be lost but if even one person
stayed calm it was enough it showed the
way for everyone to survive and so while
I was in target this morning I paused I
let everyone do their panicking the
Russian they weren't acting like
community members they're acting acting
like selfish solipsistic hoarders and
we'll talk about that in a moment but
instead of rushing along with them I
stopped by kept keeping my distance from
the workers there but about 10 feet away
I went up to some workers said hey thank
you for being here today I really
appreciate the fact that you're here I
know these are scary times but
everything's gonna be okay and you're
really helping out and after saying
that's quite a few workers you you could
see like oh they needed this calm person
because they felt the anxiety of all of
these other anxious people who were
literally door-busting we used to use
that term back in our retail days Ryan
the doorbuster sales but that's kind of
what was happening here today at Target
and so I'm so glad you bring that up man
because like that is it for anyone
listening to this when you see someone
doing their job
going about it normally like every time
I see the post office worker I had to go
to the post office uh earlier today cuz
my my grandmother who is retired
listen Florida has no toilet paper the
retirement home she's that gave her a
couple rolls but I had to go I basically
found some facial tissue
she couldn't even find that not online
not at a store near here so I do like go
to the post office and mail her mail her
some facial tissue and along the way it
was like every worker I ran into I'm
like it really means a lot that you're
doing this because if you weren't
society truly would start to break down
even more than what people think it is
so going out of your way and just saying
thank you to those people that is that's
huge that goes so far yeah what you're
talking about that Ryan is sort of
restoring some humanity because right
now we talked about this on the
preparation podcast and you can go back
and listen to it's episode 224 of the
minimalist podcast and we talked about
how you're gonna see the best of and the
worst of humanity do your best to be the
best part of humanity right now and and
I would like to make an argument right
now that these so-called Preppers are
often the least prepared for a crisis
and and the reason I say that is you
can't trade can corn and ammunition for
the support and trust of a loving
community I can tell you Ryan every
place is out of hand sanitizer right now
right mmm yeah yeah I walk to my corner
gas station and they usually sell hand
hand sanitizer you know right there at
the counter with you they have little
bin of it and so I walked in there to
buy some gum a couple days ago and and a
topo Chico and I said hey do you having
it
hand sanitizer left Padilla that's a
greeting by his name and he was like oh
no we don't but I saved one for you and
you know it's funny the I just talked
about how the Preppers are least
prepared for this and and you can't
trade the stuff for a loving community
and I tweeted that and there was someone
who said the problem is you can't eat
the trust of a loving community and my
response to that was it sounds like
you've never
a loving community because I know right
now that if for some reason Ryan I ran
out of food at my house or I ran out of
hand sanitizer in fact it's funny that
same day that I ran out of hand
sanitizer I went to go get a
prescription filled at my local pharmacy
it's a compounding pharmacy and they
know me well I walk in they know me by
name and he's like hey man do you need
any hand sanitizer I'm like I mean not
really it's got about he's got I can
compound some for you if you like but we
don't know we don't have any in stock
but I'd be happy to compound some for
you I really in and so he's a member of
my community he was looking out for me
and I know that if I ran out of food I
ran out of toilet paper
I ran out of paper towels that I've done
enough to contribute to my community up
till now that I can certainly find
someone who's willing to lend a helping
hand yeah you know it's interesting
because you keep saying the word prepper
I actually I'm part of this men's group
as you know and there's a gentleman who
was part of this group who is a prepper
and we had this was two weeks ago we had
a meeting and he was just going through
you know his ammunition and all his
supplies that he has and all the canned
cream corn whatever it is yeah but
really where his focus was it was
community and and what he was talking
about was as he was like you know I have
these things so I can take care of my
community because I'm going to need
community more than I need canned corn
because but I am prepared for you guys
to to come here and he had a white board
and like list like every single one of
our names were on it you know in a
crisis situation you know we were
pretending like it was a crisis
situation there were these jobs listed
out with each of the names and it was uh
it was just amazing man and I guess all
that to say is I think there's a
difference between running in and door
busting I don't think those people are
Preppers I think they're I think they're
hoarders and I think they're panic or
yeah and and I think that's what we need
to avoid doing I love a Trader Joe's
right now there's a line to get in
Trader Joe's and they're only allowing a
certain amount of people and I had to go
a couple days ago totally got in to add
plenty of stuff they give you a little
heads up hey you can't buy
more than two of one thing which isn't a
big deal at all and the store is more
empty than any other the slowest time
you can think of during the week and
they do that intentionally to stop
people from panicking because they
realize that the store is crowded and a
shelf starts to empty the panic starts
to set in so seeing Trader Joe's do
something like that to help people not
panic
I mean it's unfortunate that they have
to put those regulations in place right
but but yeah I mean it really what I'm
just trying to get at is the worst thing
we can do is panic and then react to
that panic I do I've totally felt
panicky during this but I haven't read I
don't reacted towards it I've had to
take a lot of deep breaths I've had to
sit here and tell myself like okay it's
gonna be okay
and it is gonna be okay but but yeah I
wish that you know the people door
busting and buying hordes of toilet
paper I wish they would think twice
before before doing panic buys it's not
even in impulse buy it's a panic buy
right and what you're doing is you're
actually hurting your community in those
situations yeah if you're listening to
this and you did it great you can't
change the past right now but what you
can do is now if you have excess you can
try to help someone who is in need
because otherwise you're doing the
opposite of being part of a community
you are you are simply creating your own
your own fortress your own toilet paper
fortress here and or food fortress or
whatever and I can tell you one thing
that I'm doing Ryan is I'm not shopping
differently from how I was before with
one exception I used to go to the
grocery store about two to three times a
week and I'd buy smaller quantities now
I'm going once a week because of social
distancing and I'm still buying the same
amount that I would for a week I'm just
buying it in one day as opposed to going
to or three times throughout the week
I'll tell you what man I will never take
for granted being able to just pop into
the grocery store because I did Mariah
and I do the same thing it's like we
kind of plan our meals out one or two
days in advance
there's Trader Joe's is right there it's
so simple we get to go for a little walk
and get groceries I mean completely
different situation now
and I don't know man I don't is there
anything else that you know I'm not
trying to pivot away from what you were
talking about but it just makes me think
about all these things that we take for
granted that that we're now noticing
like oh wow like just a simple thing as
going through the grocery store a simple
thing is being able to be in a recording
studio together when you have some you
know mild cold symptoms a simple thing
of getting guests to come out here I
mean there's so many things that are
it's hitting me in the face like I just
didn't even realize I was taking for
granted well let's talk about that
because I think what's gonna happen now
is yes we're realizing it and because we
can't go to a lot of these places
they're either closed because they have
self-regulated or depending on what
state you're in I just saw today in Ohio
Mike DeWine is shutting down all the
barber shops even oh wow and so and
beauty salons and all of that so those
are all again things that we tend to
take for granted I can just go get a
haircut right I can walk down the street
or drive a mile or two away and get a
haircut that's not a problem well I
actually can't do that right now if you
live in Dayton Ohio for example and so
that's that that's something we take for
granted a pnina I'm I'm not clairvoyant
I I don't I can't predict the future I'm
just speculating here based on I have a
lot of experience in retail and so do
you you and I are both worked in retail
during the heydays of the Oddie's we
also worked in retail and managed a lot
of retail stores in 2008 when the bottom
fell out of the market and and here's
what I can tell you I three months ago
you remember this Ryan I was predicting
a retail apocalypse before all of this
this coronavirus stuff yeah and what I
noticed now just walking down the street
today is there's more and more empty
shops and a lot of these are mom-and-pop
shops that you they're unprofitable the
first 21 to 28 days of the month that
means they make all their profit they're
in the red the vast majority of the
month the last three to eight days of
the month usually is where they are
profitable which is usually fine
if you're open 30 or 31 days a month but
right now you're gonna have places
closed for at least two weeks I think
it's going to extend much farther than
that oh yeah and you're not gonna you're
gonna go back to these places and
they're not going to reopen there's
gonna be a lot of gyms a lot of
restaurants a lot of studio spaces
jiu-jitsu studios and and bars and
barber shops and salons and in all of
these different places that actually
just aren't going to reopen after this
and that is going to cause a bit of a
spiral I think this isn't to make anyone
panic this is to say you talk about this
between hoarding and preparing earlier
Ryan this is say be prepared and also be
appreciative for what we have if you are
someone who works in the service
industry and I know a lot of people
listen this podcast do and Ryan and I
worked in the service industry for a
very long time you can pivot and now is
a good time to pivot because there are
going to be a lot of service jobs that
are gonna be different right if you work
at your local bar or look local
restaurant you may for the time being be
out of a job it doesn't mean you you
can't do something else you know that
they are the the nature of service is
changing and so a lot of delivery places
are really ramping up how many people
they're hiring and it doesn't mean just
working for some of these apps like post
mates or someone like that although
that's a good short-term solution but a
lot of these places have their own
delivery people and and so realizing the
service industry is going to I think
make a dramatic shift I think the retail
industry is going to make the shift it
was going to make over the next 18 to 24
months that shift is gonna be made over
the next 12 to 16 weeks yeah I totally
agree there is I mean what I'm hearing
you say is that there is a recession
coming I mean if you look at the stock
market and yeah businesses who were you
already hear business owners talking
about how they might have to shut their
doors yeah the question is it's not if
it's when and then when it starts you
know when this current uh buyer is
saying I don't know if it's going to
take a vaccine to get
through this or maybe the numbers will
start to drop off with all of this
social distancing and these curfews that
are being put in place but maybe you
know we'll be able to recover but you
know my inclination is to say yeah it's
gonna take what did you say six to
twelve weeks it's gonna take 60 probably
12 12 to 16 weeks probably yeah so 12 to
16 weeks it might take us 12 to 16
months to try to just start it start to
get back to normal yeah yeah and in fact
I feel like we're about 18 months away
of of getting back to normal but I'm
gonna put a caveat on that it's gonna be
a new normal and I think we're actually
gonna see immense growth from this I was
talking to our mutual friend Sean
mihalick today he teaches my writing
class with me he's a very talented
novelist and we were we were just going
back and forth today and he said you
know I think some incredibly positive
stuff is going to happen in the world
once this virus is under control and
we're gonna adapt in in powerful ways
economically medically governmental II
technologically and through these times
you're gonna see a lot of innovation you
know we're gonna see fewer things that
are touch-based
doors are gonna start opening like they
did on Star Trek and and a lot more
things are going to be voice-activated
including elevators and and and the
medical field is going to to change and
we realize like oh no we only have a
hundred thousand ventilators and four
hundred thousand beds in the United
States
yeah that's nuts well actually have an
epidemic response team in place probably
yeah we just might again and and so
we're gonna learn a whole lot from this
and in the meantime I won't want to just
say this you we're we're talking about
you what to do everyone knows to wash
their hands we're on an hour and getting
around here to tell you to wash your
hands and keep six feet away from people
you already know that so we know that
for the time being that's the best thing
to do but let's also talk about how we
can use this time wisely because
quarantine this is now the time for you
to really create we're not going out and
consuming anymore all that
zooming we took for granted most of it
were realizing right now oh I didn't
need to do that in the first place and
now this is being thrust upon me right
this is the time to create and I'm not
saying you have to create your
masterpiece right now but maybe you've
always wanted to write a short story
maybe you've wanted to write a book
maybe you've wanted to start a blog by
the way we've got a great a great guide
to start a blog
it's just the minimalists comm slash
blog we've had over 20,000 people use
that thing to start their own blogs it's
exactly how we started our blog ten
years ago and it's the best creative
decision we've ever done because it led
to all these other things with the
podcast the the tours the books the the
films etc it all started with starting a
blog or maybe you want to start a
podcast Ryan and I have a guide for that
as well it's just the minimalists comm
slash microphone and maybe you wanted to
learn a new skill guitar or yoga or
something else now is the time to do
that because you have the time and yes
of course you know you can spend it
watching reruns on on Netflix or
whatever and of course there's a time
and place for that or maybe you wanted
to read a bunch of books
you probably have a bookshelf full of
books you haven't read now's a good time
to start cracking into those you know
I'm trying to finish this book with you
Ryan right now I love people use things
and I'm gonna be using this time to
finish this book and I'm reading more
books as a result reading more articles
and you know what I'm gonna do less of
is I'm going to read less about the
coronavirus I think it's good to be
informed I think being bludgeoned with
information is a bad thing yeah not only
be watching out for breaking news is
going to break you oh yeah that's so odd
cache on well Ryan I've got this article
I want to read some of it because I
think it will be helpful here it's our
friend Cal Newport yeah he wrote the
book digital minimalism and he has this
blog post and we'll put a link to it in
the show notes as well but it's called
on digital minimalism and pandemics and
it goes a little something like this
one of the more profound representations
of the soul and Western the Western
canon is the chariot allegory from
Plato's dialogue and it says the chariot
the charioteer of human soul drives a
pair and secondly one of the horses is
Noble and it is Noble and of noble breed
but the other quite is quite the but the
other is quite the opposite and breed
and character and then he goes on to say
as elaborated by the character of
Socrates in the dialogue the charity R
represents our souls reasoned pursuit to
cultivate a worthy life this task
requires the charity R to allow the
noble steed representing our moral
intuitions to lead the way while
preventing its ignoble partner
presenting our base instincts from
drawling the soul off course in digital
minimalism I use this allegory to help
understand help understand how to
navigate both the promises and the
perils of modern technology the
minimalist I argue deploys technology in
specific intentional ways with the goal
of empowering the noble steed the
maximalist by contrast deploys
technology casually allowing it to a
measurable measurably boost the strength
of the other horse I'm bringing this up
now because it occurred to me that these
ideas have probably never been more
relevant than a myths the anxiety caused
by the corona virus pandemic in this
current situation for most people the
constant monitoring of online news about
the virus is providing pure fuel to the
ignoble to the ignoble steed dragging
the allegorical chariot away from what's
good and all inspiring about life even
during turmoil and toward bottomless
anxiety and pseudo paralysis the ignoble
steed always craves more of this
attention catching information what if
something extra terrible just happened
what if I find a link that makes me feel
better
but in this feverish pursuit the
charioteer
loses control there is I propose a
simple two-part solution to this state
of affairs first check one national and
one local news source each morning then
and this is the important part
don't check any other news for the rest
of the day presumably if time-sensitive
updates that effect you if there are any
they will be they'll arrive to you
directly by email phone or text this
will be really hard get especially given
the way we've been trained by social
media companies over the past decade to
view our phone as a psychological
pacifier which brings me to the second
part of the solution distract yourself
with value-driven action so he goes on
to say don't this doesn't mean abandon
all technology I'll let you read the
rest of the article there Ryan will know
I love this paper - always yeah he is he
is showing us how to stay informed
instead of drowning ourselves with
information or drowning ourselves with
technology for that matter totally agree
and that's the thing we can use the
technology to our benefit we could check
it once in the morning make sure that
you know the world still exists outside
the the walls of our quarantined homes
and then and this is the big part after
that focus on he says creating something
of value but but I or doing some of the
value driven but I would say create
something of value right yeah do
something that is worthwhile and we
talked about some examples there but
there's something you've been meaning to
do and I just haven't had the time
well guess what now you do time was an
excuse before and you did have the time
we all have the same 24 hours in the day
but now you're recognizing it use those
hours wisely a ma'am I think maybe we
wrap it up on this there's a tweet from
Mike Birbiglia his standard why special
a wise philosopher Michael yeah this new
comedy special was really great it's
about parenting if you're a parent
you'll really enjoy it it's on Netflix
anyway his tweet says let's be honest
social distancing from a few certain
people has been nice
oh wow that's great that's yes indeed so
Ryan let's just let's just say this now
is not a time for alarm it's not a time
for panic it is a time for awareness for
caution for vigilance and for acting
accordingly you know it is a time for
social distancing is for acting
appropriately because we want to be
responsible for the people around us
even if you're not scared of the virus
for yourself you may pass it on to
someone else even if you pass it on to a
kid and they're asymptomatic they may
pass it on to a grandparent and if that
grandparent is really struggling with
their health then you know the mortality
rate is upwards of 20% for people over
80 and just older people in general are
at much higher risk here if you're
looking for a deep dive into the science
we'll put a link in to in the show notes
so Paul Saladino really broke down the
science between Tsarskoe v2 and also the
first SARS virus which we know as SARS
right we when you hear about SARS it's
just so Tsarskoe v1 the difference is
there between that and also the flu
virus and and MERS and and some
different viruses but also what we can
do to keep our immune systems healthy
during these times and Paul believes
that if you have a strong immune system
that's really gonna be your best defense
and all of this it's not going to
prevent you from getting kovat 19 but it
will certainly help you fighting it
fight it off if if you do yeah no I
think it's important people they do dig
into this science because some of it I
don't know it's some of it makes me
panic more but then other pieces of it
kind of alleviates some of the the crazy
you know panic that I that I do
experience but ultimately a man like
this is what I hope this quick episode
does for people it helps them a to panic
less I hope it helps them to first and
foremost take care of yourself and make
sure you're healthy and that your
friends and family that they're taking
care of but also ask what you can do for
your community well you know is there an
elderly person next door you can help
out with I Los Angeles is a different
place right now man like it is I have
never have never seen people so friendly
in LA and it's unfortunate that it takes
something like this to happen in order
for people to act that way but I am
grateful for it and you know as long as
we keep treating each other well and as
long as we teep keep taking the
appropriate precautions we're gonna get
through this just fine but before you go
and buy 67 rolls of toilet paper you
know make sure someone else has it
before you take it all yeah yeah let's
let's think about others obviously we
need to think about ourselves but let's
think about others and realize that you
are going to be just fine even if you
don't have toilet paper you're gonna be
fine and maybe just maybe maybe you
needed this challenge right now maybe
this is going to put you in that
discomfort zone and maybe you needed
that maybe you're going to thrive
because you're getting through this time
of survival and it's going to make you
stronger as a result maybe you needed
this reset maybe I did too and maybe we
all needed to slow down a bit
because we were going a little bit too
fast and we can't keep going at that
speed forever we're gonna experience
some whiplash but guess what we're all
gonna heal let's heal together all right
Joe love people use things see you next
time see you thanks guys minimus